[Music]
in surgery while awake news oh my
nightmares are you write me oh yes these
actually that's crazy that's crazy
we're like freaking out all about you
can see huh know how to put a drape you
seen videos so surgery it looks so rough
sometimes I don't seem like like quadri
attachment there yeah they're just [ __ ]
it's crazy
I've heard of people who like they get
put under but they're still conscious I
think that's where we're headed I think
that's where we're headed see straight
they tape patients eyes just in case I
would ask for a mirror yeah we can't
react or they can't talk I got my wisdom
teeth removed while I was uh novocaine
deduct and I was conscious of everything
and I was like this is an interesting
experience you hear it pop - I can put
me under I wanted to so bad they didn't
were they just numbed it local local
anesthesia doing me I think I got like
15 shots or someone's the shots hurt a
lot yeah this side because nothing in
and nothing in nothing you know like a
beautiful day my uh my friend in Vietnam
got his like ACL me whatever surgery
done and the doctor said you know they
don't give a [ __ ] like he was the best
doctor everyone says he was the best
doctor and then the best doctor don't
give a [ __ ] right no yeah he went he
went there to UM that's his actual
commercial hi I'm dr. Tran I don't give
a [ __ ] imagine going to the doctor here
just a few surgeries huh like you was on
the phone in amis bark barber and
smoking this [ __ ] [ __ ] man you
know [ __ ] Maura
ask the Bluetooth
and I think it was like he was awake
during the time so they have a TV screen
where you can watch your surgery going
down or something just on the phone you
can see your knee getting worked on then
he's not looking at his teeth in the TV
like yeah right and yeah yeah you're
like hello I'm right here oh man he's
taking a selfie all right submitted by
its head hey Ted power into the article
man haven't heard Ted in a minute I
don't know any Ted to a detail in
character no one names their kid Ted
anymore what is this draw is it short
for Eddie Theodore Theodore a woman of
recounts recounts how many sang opera
while surgeons removed her brain oh I
saw this she was singing opera while
they were moving it is she like an opera
singer though because you know what if
they messed up a wire Japanese suddenly
yeah she does have like training okay
Joe
but she's Mimi I don't want pictures I'm
up oh you don't like this I follow like
two or three instagrams that are like
for trauma and like combat medical
shouldn't be I don't know I saw this one
where this dude he had a tree branch
like this big go into his mouth and come
out the back of his tree branch this big
and went like I think he fell off a tree
in a way not decapitated I don't know
just went right through and they had to
cut the branch off so he went through
went to the hospital like oh I just
pictured this fool fought like he's like
a sniper and then he falls and he gets
caught but he's like caught through the
[ __ ] mouth and he's holding the tree
branch scare you as you're scrolling
you're like all those things that are
fall I'm looking with all that but if a
[ __ ] video or a picture of childbirth
comes up I'm out I like those two I
follow those scares there should have
actual regular like medical hospital
ones so there's like like stuff like
that and then and they always have like
like sensitive warning you know it's all
blurt it out I'm like damn it I do want
I want to see this you don't have to
tell
at least they have that the brain
surgeries don't like they strap you in
so your heads completely still and they
actually open you up and they have you
have to be awake so you can respond I
mean what kind of brain surgery it is
yeah
so this one that's so crazy this girl
she's 34 years old she's a stand-up
comedian and and and a special needs
teacher no she's a special person yeah
so then I wonder if she has any jokes
about her kids oh yeah I'm just
wondering if she does that's why the
main because you're supposed to find
inspiration from your daily life I'm
just wondering if she literally just
became a school teacher for that mmm
special yes sir her name was Sarah May
she's from Scotland and apparently she
had been living with this tumor that she
didn't know about for the last 15 years
and so finally they found it how do you
not know about it cuz she was symptom
free you don't know until yeah it's like
maybe got a small brain now maybe you
get a small brain is just hiding it's
just inside there randomly you get like
a brain scan like oh [ __ ] what's that
[ __ ] sea slugs in the right this
white spot they finally discovered it
once she suffered a seizure in 2016 oh
yeah so then she was just telling her
story of how like she remembers when she
was getting operated on and they needed
her to be a wait like they they woke her
up in the middle of the surgery the
first they opened her up and everything
oh god damn frightening right here of
what what is this Sarah made you do it
either and her fiance Scotland is like
no the white mountains are the only
place that Scotland's they did shoot in
Scotland photo the surgery sued nothing
no blood that's already forgot I see so
bad uh yeah and so she was just saying
that Bobby Bobby that'll suck if you if
you get woken up and then you [ __ ]
gotta eat your head saw your number
but then like just to imagine it you
know these things yeah you got a writ
you got a itch it you scratching your
brain yeah yeah okay I can you scratch
my head you're awake and they poked
parts your brain your leg starts kicking
in [ __ ] start singing opera yeah if you
have like a phantom itch so like you
think your scalp still there but they
already cut it open and then so you go
like this and it's like now you go over
here you go over here and scratch your
head cuz it's on the side that's I give
yourself a little bit [ __ ] your brains
out I am Wiesel it was part of count
check out they had this live I've got
Boonen I am Wiesel yeah with the fence
and lagers or tail or something anyway
so back to her so then she started
saying that thanks for the reference
haha just in case anyone seen it alright
so this operation was about nine hours
she said that the whole time like she
was just talking to the staff I'm
cracking up jokes comedians
international flight she's cracking up
jokes la he's getting great size you
could probably hear the drills going
through her brain and remember you could
smell it yeah memory the burned flesh
but in the Carter ization it was like so
she was meant to be awake this whole
time yeah did she know she was awake
they had to keep her awake in order for
them not to [ __ ] up certain parts of her
brain because they're saying that if
she's saying that they took out the size
of a tennis ball out of her head because
the tumor was just pretty good me a
headache the tumor was taking over her
brain and this whole time for 15 years
her brain has just adapted to the change
yeah this is fine it's fine
it's like an asian grandma when there's
more at the side of the bread they just
cut around yeah but everything else is
COO
yes so they left about 15% of the tumor
because then if they would have removed
that I would have affected her speech
and movement
oh so that's what they're poking to see
yeah it'll grow imagine oh my god
imagine you're talking like yeah no I'm
having a
great day today holy [ __ ] oh but they
can't take all of it back let's put that
back cut out everything like they cut
out because of her memory they start
changing your personality she's
performing other buddy yeah oh he starts
crying and then she would make up songs
about the staff around her and then she
would tease the surgeon sounds Pleasant
the best patient yeah well past the time
people down are the happiest are the
[ __ ] craziest watch out it was me I
would not be singing dude I would be
[ __ ] freaking the funky - I'd be like
that's but she I got some drugs rolling
to her right for sure let me show you
some more photos you guys know how
squeamish I am I'll tell you you're not
that squeamish you're probably more than
better it's like cabbage so this was the
tumor taken over her bridge I'm hoping
the black stuff all the black stuff oh
did I picture like a ball inside the
head to be completely honest with you
I'm guessing cuz they don't tell me so
I'm guessing okay all right so then
right down here it says I have had brain
absences a seizure an awake craniotomy
IVF treatment and so far five bouts of
chemotherapy leaving me with the
exhaustion of an old woman all within
the last seven months that the last one
was the hardest and then this is her
after her story
how is she so positive she was like a
mushroom she does Mario yeah mushroom of
the Mario way
chod yeah this pink photo after her oh
don't break my spirit these red dots you
gotta put red box everywhere she looks
like that one goldfish boy remember the
goldfish boy but he also had a freaking
tumor oh or cancer positive okay I've
heard what it was that he had but Will
Smith and hitch yeah yeah hate some
shrimp damn cigarette bill Bismol yeah
that's so good dad you could have a good
spirit during a time of like you about
to [ __ ] die nobody I would have a
[ __ ] breakdown
I what I want to know is like is she
knowing to choose to sing Ave Maria well
where's the drugs like singing yeah like
you can have a memory of like being
really drunk right you have memory but
you're like now I didn't really decide
to just [ __ ] she was like she was
trained in like opera singing yeah but
like so I'm my head's over here yeah
yeah yeah it's like I'm gonna I know
this guy's working on I am aware this
guy's working on my brain right now and
I'm gonna crack everybody up I'm gonna
make this nurse yeah well like they were
like working on it and it like triggered
some [ __ ] like I'm gonna do some
freestyle rap yeah yeah yeah or this is
just what I do I'm gonna let it go it's
like a reflex you know like when you go
to the doctor if I can do that [ __ ] on
your knee and your leg just kicks up
like that dude when I woke up from my
search here they're like oh my god your
life is so interesting apparently I had
a whole full-on [ __ ] conversation you
didn't choose to tell me your life no no
who is it that's what I'm wondering
[Music]